you've also um talk about some of the
soundtrack [ __ ] because you've you've
had some some dope moments yeah on the
space jam just yeah man like shout out
to archie man for for putting that
together how big of a deal because i
mean you're a basketball fan a huge
basketball fan so and space jam is just
i mean it's our age it's like bro i mean
bro to be a part of like space bro this
is space jam bro it's insane like space
junior but like well like i don't know
how many times you've watched space you
know a lot growing up i was a huge
jordan fanatic yeah like like i've
probably watched that movie how however
many times then i have all the toys
still yeah like low g toys
i remember uh j uh jr's mom sold his uh
his like big ass michael jordan one for
like five bucks she was like yeah i just
sold it you know you're gonna put that
on ebay
general is so sick but yeah but um
um
but yeah like i mean just to be a part
of
this is like but like spatially i'm
gonna like stand to the test of time
you know what i'm saying we'll see about
this one though
bro i mean come on just as a film yeah
but i mean bro come on bro i'm going to
say this about the film i think i think
and i'm a lebron stan my favorite player
ever
i think people were a little bit too
harsh on the movie bro because it's too
hot bro i actually thought the movie was
was was pretty like it was no it was
[ __ ] incredible bro it was [ __ ]
cgi'd out like i actually thought it
wasn't bad
i was like yeah when i watched it i was
like expecting it to be like a steaming
pile of dog [ __ ] and i was like yo this
[ __ ] is what i thought it was going to
be oh like people act like they're about
to get like denzel
come on bro
people just hate lebron no people just
know you know what not even just lebron
but people just be hating
on everything everything we're in the
era of everyone everybody just be hating
brother like bro oh he's voicing your
opinion like a [ __ ] hater yeah
especially about children a children's
[ __ ] children's movie bro yeah
come on bro
it's bugs bunny in there yeah like bro
what
like
like
what are y'all bro come on brother when
they had the [ __ ] from game of
thrones in here i said oh this [ __ ]
come on bro
like [ __ ] be just
always just want to hate bro everyone
wants to hate just voicing your opinion
like a [ __ ] hater